[Musique]
bonjour et bon livre à toutes et à tous
donc noël approche et le livre c'est
comme un reste un magnifique cadeau de
noël hélas les tous importants et jean
de la bruyère disait par exemple quand
une lecture vous élève l'esprit et
qu'elle vous inspire des sentiments
nobles et courageuse ne cherchez pas une
autre règle pour juger de l'ouvragé
il est bon effet demain d'ouvriers alors
nous allons essayer de vous faire
découvrir de bons livres etc les
rebelles dans qui est comédienne et
comédienne et chanteuse va nous parler
d'un livre original c'est reflet de ma
vie alors seul il n'est pas de moi il
est dan toile arthus-bertrand donc
reflet de ma vie c'est une
autobiographie mais c'est surtout un
cadeau un cadeau que anne fait à son
mari à ses enfants et plus largement à
toutes les personnes qu'elle aime et à
toutes les personnes qui liront ce livre
quand on parle de la discrétion de la
pudeur des gens on ne voit pas les
douleurs enfermé on ne pense pas au
poids du si l'ensemble on voit cette
qualité humaine qui est que la personne
est à l'écouté qu'elle sait rester en
retrait anin et psychothérapeute ans
elle a accompagné des hommes et des
femmes pendant de longues années
elle est mariée au très célèbre
photographe
yann arthus bertrand elle a trois
enfants trois garçons des petits enfants
mais anne est malade
anna la maladie de parkinson depuis
maintenant presque vingt ans dans son
livre elle raconte sa vie depuis son
enfance sa vie avec ses parents sa vie
avec ses frères et puis sa vie de femme
avec toujours cette place la place de la
discrète à la place de celle qui ne
dérange pas aujourd'hui anne ne peut
plus exercer
elle est fragilisée par sa maladie
cependant je me demande si sa maladie ne
lui a pas donné la force d'écrire ce
livre
tout à l'heure je vous disais que ce
livre était un cadeau oui c'est un
cadeau parce qu'en fait c'est un
encouragement un encouragement à
exprimer ce qu'on ressent
merci anne mais je crois que ça très
beau témoignage comme tous les
témoignages d'une fois yann
arthus-bertrand il fait un travail
tellement fantastique pour le la planète
tout ça c'est formidable
il habite pas très loin d'ici à au menu
tout seul formule 1
merci clair donc suzy maltret va nous
parler maintenant de série ana rooney
qui a écrit notamment sur l'arménie
c'est ça donc il sera là au salon des
écrivains de rambouillet c'est un
monsieur
c'est un monsieur qui a écrit je crois
70 livres aussi bien chez marie vol
comme meilleur c'est un monsieur qui qui
connaît qui c'est qui va analyser un et
j'en veux pour preuve ce titre
l'arménie un passé sans sépulture qui
conte l'histoire de cette famille
arménienne contraintes de fuir les
persécutions alep ou ailleurs et elle
est tellement actuelle un peuple
ballotté sacrifier massacrés et contre
de s'installer ailleurs voir en france
un livre est un livre universel qui nous
pousse à nous dire c'est quoi l'humain
c'est quoi le sol où nous sommes c'est
quoi cet être qui est en face moi qu'est
ce qu'il est
qu'est ce qu'il est pour moi qu'est-ce
qu'il veut que je devienne moi qui
aimais mater et puis bernard ne vous l'a
pas dit mais aussi et je pense que ce
sera la surprise du salon
il a écrit un livre que j'ai trouvée
magnifique et qui s'appelle perles ou
pearl ou pearl où c'est un noir voilà
aussi avec le dernier y en avait peu
mais ils étaient là ils étaient là pour
la construction de la tour eiffel du
sacré coeur et c'est tout ce pari qui
défilent devant vos yeux vous pouvez pas
le ps ne pouvait pas louper ça
vous pouvez pas louper l'enterrement de
victor hugo ou que nous voulons dit que
cette foule était singulière étonnante
émouvante prodigieuse qu'on ne reverra
plus d échelle étaient loués par la
multitude et toute proche étaient
qu'avranches lisez cet auteur autour
d'eux je crois ne pas me tromper entre
50 et 70 ouvrages
c'est un monsieur que aucun éditeur ne
refuse merci ses yeux c'est bien de
parler de dénoncer les génocides
arménien et ça recommence et que les
kurdes
voilà les organisations internationales
il est à la fois dans notre passé et à
la fois dans la mouvance du présent
merci fusil mais nathalie bol donc qui
est maître de conférences à l'université
de versailles saint quentin va nous
parler de dracula dans la new york
d'halloween de l'état
merci bernard oui j'ai choisi de vous
parler de dracula un peu moins pour
l'amour ans halloween que parce qu'il ya
quand même un événement majeur cette
année c'est l'entrée dans la pléiade
prestigieuse collection gallimard de
dracula donc ça s'intitule dracula et
autres écrivons pierrick et c'est vrai
que je trouve que c'est un peu justice
rendue parce que de dracula on voit
tient aujourd'hui surtout les
adaptations cinéma y en avait des
magnifiques un nosferatu le dracula de
coppola a rien du tout 40 et donc ça
fait quand même du bien aussi de revenir
au texte originel alors dans ce volume
qui est vraiment exceptionnel
évidemment on trouve le dracula de bram
stocker avec vous cette soulte est ce ce
personnage ce jeune anglais qui est
correct pour à l'invitation d'un certain
compte de transylvanie qui va le
recevoir dans son château
donc il ya ce texte magnifique mais il
n'ya pas que ça moi j'ai découvert des
écrits vraiment très très intéressant
d'abord un court roman de polidori qui
est considéré comme étant le texte
pionnier en matière décrit vampirique
on va trouver des fragments de lord
byron on va trouver des poèmes
on va trouver des variantes féminine de
dracula la fameuse carmilla enfin bref
vraiment beaucoup de diversité est un
très très beau recueil et c'est vrai que
dracula qui a été écrit quand même au
19e siècle nous passionne toujours ce
extraordinaire sens
il ya des thèmes qui sont universels le
désir la métamorphose l'altérité la
figure de l'autre oui la vérité je l' ai
déjà dit l'identité et bien sûr la peur
et c'est fascinant parce qu'avec dracula
on est attirés en même temps la peur et
puis on a besoin d'avoir peuvent re
le besoin d'avoir peur alors moi j'adore
ce mythe parce que c'est vraiment un
mythe
et c'est ça m'a conduit je pense à mon
aspire un petit peu et je signale la
parution d'un album jeunesse ou à la
voix par exemple sur l'écran que j'ai
écrit dracula et moi qui raconte
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui part
sur les traces de ses grands parents des
grands parents qui avaient dit et
pourchassés y avait dû fuir leur pays et
le grand père a laissé son manuscrit
inachevé
alors la petite fille part en quête de
ce manuscrit c'est une quête sur les
origines et dracula dans ce livre est
présenté comme une métaphore de la
tyrannie une métaphore de la guerre et
alors ce livre il a été illustrée par
une peintre que j'admire beaucoup qui a
fait plus de 20 albums jeunesse qui
s'appelle elsa auriol donc juste eu pour
avoir une idée voilà de la douceur de
ses unes de ses peintures c'est comme ça
un peu intemporel très doux beaucoup de
force et il serait sur le gâteau pantxo
le dessinateur de presse au canard
enchaîné nous a fait l'honneur d'une sa
participation voilà le livre sans fin du
mois une très bonne idée de cadeau de
noël c'est bien donc maintenant jean
charles lajoie nikki éditeur va nous
parler d'un roman policier d'un roman
policier là on va changer je propose un
vrai voyage que là nous sommes dans la
banlieue ouest
et là on part dans la banlieue est donc
exactement l'opposé d'ici si on trace
une droite est traversé par lyon centre
de l'autre côté et l'associant des
aventures d'un détective privé qui va
lutter contre les malfaisants qui ont
pris la banlieue en otage alors c'est un
retour aux sources puisque il
le détective le et rouge thomas efira
revient dans sa dans sa banlieue à
l'occasion de l'enterrement d'un vieux
copain de collège il avait 20 ans qui
les portons et dans sa banlieue ont lieu
dans lequel il ya vécu dont il a eu il a
fait toute sa scolarité et là il
découvre une ville va qui n'a plus rien
à voir avec ce que c'était enfin une
ville gangrénée par le peuple par les
truands par les mafias par les dealers
par les imams crapuleux
les femmes par tout ce qu'on peut
trouver dans certaines banlieues mais
avec bien évidemment une belle nuance
d'espoir parce qu il dit au delà de tout
ça cette banlieue reste à une banlieue
avec effectivement des gens qui sont
extrêmement en cohésion entre qui
luttent effectivement contre les dérives
religieuses de certains les dérives
mafieuses des autres les dérives des
hommes politiques qui ont pris la ville
quasiment en coupe réglée et qui alors
ça rappelle bien évidemment quelques
quelques allusions à l'actualité s'est
jamais nommée mais il ya un député maire
qui a tendance une fâcheuse tendance à
acheter les voix de ses électeurs pour
arriver à se faire réélire alors
l'intérêt du livre au delà de tout ce
que ça raconte c'est vraiment
extrêmement prenant cesser le le ton et
le style de l'auteur c'est extrêmement
drôle et l'histoire et comme très noir
mais c'est extrêmement drôle on a eu
déjà des des premiers papiers sur ce
livre gens qui parlent entre san antonio
léo malet nos de victor hugo qui s'était
enfin tout le monde reconnaît à ce à
cette hauteur un style certain et
remarqua et puis surtout beaucoup
d'humour ce qui est très agréable
donc c'est très bien donc jean baptiste
ferrero banlieue est roman policier mais
pas que de tokyo à un roman policier il
ya roman c'est quand vous voilà qualifié
mais c'est pas que du policier il y
avait un autre chose c'est ce qui fait
tout l'intérêt à mon sens durant deux
policiers c'est tout ce que ça raconte
au delà de l'énigme au delà de
l'intrigué
no mercy danseur né pour abonder dans
votre sens que vous parlez aussi d'un
polar ou un roman policier c'est burn
out de didier faussaires qui avait eu le
prix du lion's-club au salon de
rambouillet il ya en 2015 et donc qui
est intéressant donc ceux qui parlent
vraiment d'un problème société actuelle
burn out dès cette année par un il ya
déjà plus de 50 policiers qui se sont
suicidés quoi qu'on me sort notre livre
we dance revient
un nouveau qui sort en salles ou deux au
colorado
alors oubliez aussi le ils pourraient
pas venir c'est vraiment c'est ça un
ancien fonctionnaire de police un ancien
officier de police donc il connaît
parfaitement la vie d'un commissariat
et il explique tout les termes la bac
brigade de nuit tout ça tout est
expliqué tous les termes c'est très bien
fait et derrière une enquête derrière
une histoire d'en quête d'aidé trafic de
banlieue aussi et bien c'est l'histoire
la dégradation d'un officier de police
quoi qui est qui et qui est stressé par
son travail qui a des problèmes
familiaux parce qu'il ait jamais à la
maison sa femme en a ras-le-bol le
week-end ils obligés de se barrer pour
des ddd on a besoin de lui tout ça donc
il n'est pas souvent famille déjà il
appela deux jours en un congé qui
rattrapera jamais et donc voilà et là
c'est vraiment ça nous touche parce que
c'est vraiment la vie des policiers
actuelle on voit qu'ils sont en grève
les sapeurs-pompiers aussi il ya un
officier d'elancourt qu'a mis fin à ses
jours il ya quelques mois donc c'est une
réalité du terrain plus de 50 cette
année c'est énorme
il ya un problème grave les policiers au
peu de moyens ils sont débordés
sarah rejaillit sur leur vie de tous les
jours donc il faut lire ce livre il sera
au salon de thé lanco le 24 novembre
le gars très sympa et ça c'est important
à dire ça va merci merci encore
[Musique]